[Music]
you are a gift
[Music]
I know it's been difficult for eBay
leaving feel different from other kids
[Music]
you are different
[Music]
after your dad and I got married we
prayed for a baby for so long
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we believe that you came here for a
reason
he was in the barn did he find it no it
was like he was drawing
he may look like us he's now like us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so many trees is beautiful right that's
definitely not Boston
oh here we go okay so what do you think
wow this whole place is ours I even got
into throwing a whole forest as a new
backyard it was a missed kids we used to
dare each other go into the woods at
night they knew the power of that place
they feared it those woods belong to
something else
[Music]
around is bad god it may be just some
crazy folktale but there is something up
in those woods something it brings
things back
sometimes dead is better nice yoga shoot
for them
do you know anything about La Llorona
the retail woman
[Music]
was a folk town
jouso stay in the car okay and please
don't wake up your sister
I try to Stuber who did you try to stop
by your owner
[Music]
[Music]
recursive la Llorona little box saw
little soft little boxes made of ticky
tacky little boxes only this time and
they all look just the same
[Music]
you want to control your life but life
isn't a science experiment you can't
contain your world forever try doing one
thing that scares you over break okay
yeah this serves as an entry voucher for
meiosis escape rooms the first sweeper I
was immersed in room yet and win a
million dollars so I won does the game
start
I think this is the escape room we
should look for clues what are we
looking for here anything that looks
like a puzzle or code it looks like an
oven dial
well that's creepy as hell 15 months
talk about a person what's wrong with
you that was real Wow
dumb question are we outside sooner get
this figured on still we get the hell
out of here
little box watching us they know
everyone relations everything about us
this is my hospital bed me too they made
these rooms for us I've never seen
things that weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
look just
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormal
[Music]
yes last question do you know how
mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place Hospital
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]